[Musique]
exactement 50 GMT ces polymères vont les
attraper ne sont-ils pas punis
il semble un peu rien de plus qu'un
homme majeur d'avertissement dans ces années 60 avec une
rancune il n'y a rien tout le monde qui est à
neuf tout a été pris en charge
vous allez changer votre  l'esprit
[Musique]
il y a chaque étape du chemin quand le
vieil homme tourne autour de beaucoup d'entre
nous pourquoi est-ce si difficile
[Musique]
on dirait qu'il a changé peut-être que
les forces spéciales,
je suppose, sont faites pour les os,
me direz-vous  qui tue mon enfant
[Musique]
tu n'as aucune idée de qui tu fais
mais tu découvres bientôt tout coresight
veille veille vas-y et si ta femme et ta
fille te tuaient par balle
[Musique]